This person's
name Long 5 Articles Satori Satoru is
right 5 Articles Satori
Satoru will tell you something interesting.The
names that have three whites and come from each other
are all Heiban.This person's Satoru comes from this Satoru.
In other words,
Satoru is saying that this is not
right, but it is not Satoru, but it is enlightening.
People
are
WR
EnglishEnglish is
right
EnglishEnglish is here
WR
God God
is
right
God God is yes next
Ron
God God
is
right God God is right God
God is the only one God God is the greatest That's why the one who is the first to
accent  If you remember that it's coming,
then
Ron
Inu Inu is
right
Inu Inu is yes
Ron Ore
Ore is
right Ore Ore ma ma
or orana Yes
Ron Pronunciation
pronunciation
is
right Pronunciation
pronunciation is Haya and 3rd Next is
Ronarut Naru
is
right
Naruto  Yes
Long Good and
good is
right
Good and good is right If you combine all of them,
I'm good at speaking.
RightI'm still not good at it.